this is a production of Cornell
University
hello and welcome to common diseases in
the garden so I just picked up about a
dirty dozen or so of diseases that
you're likely to find where if you work
on the grow liner in your own garden and
they represent an array of diseases that
were some you see the signs of the
disease
and some you see the symptoms of the
disease and so let's just run through
them very quickly you're certainly not
expected to memorize them but just to
have a feeling for the diversity of
diseases that you'll find in the
landscape the first disease I wanted to
go over was powdery mildew funny mildew
is one of the easier diseases to
identify because there's a rightist
sized which is actually part of the
fungi that covers the leaves usually on
the top of the leaves and it's actually
a group of fungi it's not just one
specific one but they all have specific
host ranges so they're ones that hit
lilacs crab
zinnias dogwoods roses they are they're
all susceptible to powdery mildew and if
we have a cool spring and summer it's
we're almost assured of seeing this
disease so the fungal hyphae infect the
outermost leaves and then insert
essentially their mouth part as it were
although they don't have a mouth but the
feeding part into the cells and they
feed off of the photosynthate that the
plant makes as I mentioned the disease
is much more prevalent when it there's
periods of high humidity and rainfall so
in terms of a management issue you want
to keep the foliage as dry as possible
so certainly if you think that you have
a plant that's likely to get powdery
mildew let's say like a bed of
try not to overhead water those plants
try to water them so that the leaves
don't get wet most of the time party
mode is an aesthetic issue not not so
much a plant health issue but it can be
quite quite bad looking I have found
that party mother on dog woods can go
into the stems and and cause sort of a
physiological problem for for dog woods
but otherwise it just it's just
unsightly okay if you are a small home
footballer and specifically apples
you're likely to be dealing with apple
scab it's certainly one of the main
diseases that orchardists have to deal
with and it causes small spots on the
leaves no big deal but it also causes
spots on the apples it was out a call
from my pathology 101 class with dr.
Sinclair who literally wrote the book on
diseases it doesn't affect the taste of
the apple at all it's just a surface
thing that of course if you were looking
to buy an apple that looked like that on
the right you you wouldn't buy it so it
makes them unsellable the fungus
overwinters on leaves that have dropped
to the ground and and hang around and
serve as the inoculum source for the
next year's infection and there's
there's a whole there's actually
software that's written to healthy time
if you are a professional orchardist
when you have to spray your plants to
prevent apple scab but for the home
orchardist
especially if you're starting an orchard
it's really great if you can select a
resistant varieties it's going to help
reduce the amount of management effort
that you're going to have to have to
have good apples
and that if you you know have an apple
tree already and you don't want to have
apple scab where you want to limit it
there are fungicides that you can use
and basically there's not a
one-size-fits-all prescription for
fungicide because it really depends on
the weather and then you might want to
avail yourself of some of the Cornell
apple scab software programs so that you
know when to spray this could because
this is a major issue for for apple
apple growers going right from apples to
strawberries gray mold botrytis is like
powdery mildew the many botrytis fungi
and that they are characterized by
having this sort of gray mold that is
that easily comes off the plant you can
see in the picture on the right there's
the straw there's two good strawberry
sort of one on top of each other and
then just to the right of it is a great
moral defective strawberry and you can
see that the pattern of spores have just
sort of fallen off and landed on the
leaf reinfect another part of the plant
and botrytis unfortunately affects a lot
of different herbaceous plants and like
powdery mildew is favored and cool wet
springs and cool summers of course
you'll find that that's true with our
diseases a hot dry year might be tough
for the plants from a lot of point of
view but it's much easier on them from a
disease point of view because a lot of
diseases are spread by raindrops hitting
the fungus releasing the spores and the
spores move to a new part of the plant
so anytime we have a crew wet spring and
a clue and wet ish summer look to see a
lot of diseases and again people manage
botrytis by trying to not do much
overhead watering of course mother
nature is going to going to rain on the
plants but if your
on a regular basis you'd want to water
just the base of the plant not the
leaves Turks pot this is one of my
favorite diseases because it's pretty
hard to miss diagnosed and the good news
is even though this looks really
horrible it actually has pretty much no
effect on the tree it hits maples and it
hits the maples in the late part of the
growing season and that's why it really
doesn't have that much effect it gets
going and it can be you know pretty
amazingly throughout the plant and you
know these vibrant tar-like spots all
over the leaves and these are actually
small sometimes they're even they're the
size of a quarter or larger but because
they hit the plant late in the in the
growing season there's really no
management and it's really no real
effect on the tree overall and that
would be true for a lot of the diseases
that hit late in the season you know yes
they don't it makes a plant unsightly
that it really doesn't have a
physiological effect on the plant the
diseases we worry about other ones that
had in the spring and so that they're
compromising the plant throughout the
growing season diseases that hit later
in the year that only you know hit the
tower spot hits and about a month later
the leaves are falling off anyway it's
not really a big problem another one of
my favorite diseases is black not black
not hits proms Prue's and it's
especially cherries and it's this sort
of charcoal like swirling growth on the
twigs and the fungus infects the twigs
and then starts to sort of charcoal e
growth and it's really easy to see when
the tree is out of leaf it's actually
harder to see if you've got a
decent-looking cherry and it starts to
get black not you might not see it until
the winter and when the leaves drop out
so there are resistance variety so that
would probably
good idea to do if you know you have a
lot of black knot in your area
I certainly have seen in New York a lot
more black not than I see in Washington
DC area I don't know why but you seem to
have a lot of black not up here you can
prune out the affected twigs in the
winter although it might behoove you to
dip your pruners in some alcohol between
cuts just to make sure you're not
spreading it and it can it can be just
an aesthetic issue but if it gets really
going on the plant it can take it out
because essentially the growth girdles
the twig and eventually that twig dies
and so if there are enough black
mountain sections throughout a cherry
plum or prune it can kill it so again
always when you're buying new plants
look for disease resistant varieties
because diseases are hard to manage I
don't think that there's really
management for black not least I'm not
aware of it except for just cutting it
out when you when you see it Tomatoes
Tomatoes get a lot of diseases and none
of them are good and one of them is
devastating so the three that I wanted
to touch on our early blight septoria
leaf spot and then late blight starting
at the top right that's septoria at
least in my experience just about every
tomato plant on the lower leaves starts
to get septoria and depending on how you
manage the disease like some people I
would just go in there religiously and
strip out the lower leaves when they
start getting septoria to keep the
infection to a minimum some people just
say oh well not to worry I'm going to
get my tomatoes and that's it so it's up
to you to decide whether you want to
manage it that way or if you want to
spray a fungicide to try to keep some
toya to a minimum but it seems to me
that
every every tomato's gonna get it there
are bill resistant varieties but it
seems like it's ubiquitous and tomatoes
also somewhat ubiquitous is early blight
and early causes more of a necrosis with
septoria is spots or the bright has sort
of a motive that is more like margin
relief the closest and into necrosis of
the leaves and that can be pretty
serious and and really keep your tomato
harvest much smaller than it would be
without the early blight but then
there's the devastating late blight and
then late like ten ironically come
somewhat early in the season but it
tends to be a little bit later in the
season and it causes these like dark
anchors on the stems and then hits the
foliage and it can wipe out the plant
just a hundred percent dead so there's
pretty much no tolerance for late blight
where you can tolerate septoria and you
can tolerate a little early light
there's really no tolerance for late
right and unless you're a hundred
percent vigilant and taking out and
inspecting your plants on a regular
basis and removing the one that starts
to have late blight
most look like it's going it's gonna
wipe out your your um your crop
so again resistant varieties there's a
list on the Cornell vegetable website in
what I've varieties that we think are
late flight resistant using fungicides
to keep it at bay but it certainly is a
bad problem that comes a those each year
sometimes it's a really bad late bite
season sometimes it's not so bad so
because tomatoes are probably our most
important vegetable crop in the home
garden it's important to know each
diseases and certainly we'll have
workshops all where we really take a
look at this because you you want to see
this up close and personal
okay so now let's talk about diseases
where you see the symptoms but not the
signs of the disease cold injury a lot
of times when people come in and they
show me samples like on the the two
leftmost pictures like what's hid what
disease is hitting my my plants well it
was really it was cold injury so it's an
abiotic disease nonliving and it's it
can be very hard to diagnose partly
because a lot especially with evergreens
the damage isn't going to show up for a
month or two and so people by the time
it's 70 degrees you forget how bad the
winter was or maybe not with this year
and they forget that that's that you
know these plants especially the other
green plants that were exposed all
winter long can have get this kind of
damage and on the right is a picture of
a tree Finbar tree probably of maple and
they can get cold injury to frost cracks
where especially on the south side where
the bark would warm up in this in the
winter and a close but sunny day and
then perhaps the Sun goes behind a cloud
and it's back to the very very cold
temperatures and the bark can't expand
and contract that fast and can cause a
frost crack so clove injury is something
that it's subtle you have to keep a kind
of an eye on the weather and and a
memory in terms of what the cold was
that winter and especially if plants are
susceptible to cold injury when it's not
only cold but it's so frozen that the
plants can't take up water so they they
actually desiccate and so you see more
like a drying out damage so that's close
injury salt damage on a year especially
like the one we've just had there's a
lot of salt on
Rhodes and I love this picture on the
top right that's salt spray damage where
you can see they use got hit directly
with salt and the salt actually
desiccates the needles that salt is
saltier than inside the plant and the
plant tries to equivalent the router
potential and so what is drawn out of
the needles into the salt at around that
are coating the needles and and kill the
plant needle out writing you can see
some bearing on the pine foliage on the
bottom right and then my my personal
favorite salt damage is on deciduous
trees which you wouldn't think would
have a problem but under heavy heavy
heavy salt spray damage the buds are
killed but especially the terminal buds
they're repeatedly killed by the salt
and the plant keeps trying to shoot
shoot out new shoots to accommodate the
loss of that terminal twig and you get
this what we call witch's broom so in
without damage this you can get salt
spray damage and you can get yourself
goes into the soil and become makes the
roots actually lose water because the
roots become less salty than the soil
around it and water is drawn out from
the root into the soil there's not a
whole lot you can do this for salts for
damage if you know you're going to have
salt damage to the roots you can leech
this excess salt through the soil
profile south is mobile earnest air
doesn't get bound up in the south
profile so usually we don't have to
worry about it too much because usually
a winter harsh winters followed by a
bunch of spring rains and those rains
flush the salt through the soil profile
but if you if you dumped a bag of so I'm
sorry dump the back of de-icing salts on
one of your favorite plants by mistake
you could obviously try to remove as
much salt as possible and then
flush it out on this spring with water
just keep watering that plant in the
early spring and hopefully the soil
salts will move through the soil profile
and away from your higgs brought to 95
blossoms rod is a tomato disease were
and sometimes pepper where you get our
lesion or sort of that yeah kind of a
mushy black lesion on the one side of
the tomato on the end of the tomato and
this is actually a calcium uptake
deficiency so in this case where most of
the diseases for tomatoes are worse when
it's wet this is a disease when it's
that's worse when it's dry because the
tomato is rapidly expanding that leaves
calcium is one of the main ingredients
in cell walls so as the plant is growing
if it doesn't get enough calcium it has
problems with the new growth and it
can't especially if it's dry just kick
in enough calcium up into the plant and
you start getting comes up blossom and
run
there are resistant tolerant varieties
so you may want to do that in somewhat
rainy New York we don't seem to have it
so badly but just be careful if you we
are having a dry summer to make sure
your tomatoes are well irrigated so
that'll help keep calcium uptake going
so you won't have the boss blossom and
rod finally verticillium wilt
verticillium wilt effects some of our
most beloved plants it seems to be
particularly harsh on Japanese maples
and on red buds but it hits a number of
plants certainly automate those species
and you can see in the upper left-hand
corner there's some Japanese maples and
they're just really thinning out looking
unthrifty
not very good aesthetically that's
probably verticillium wilt and then in
the bottom picture is a maple with some
bridge die back and that again is
probably verticillium wilt it's a little
bit hard to diagnose sometimes because
it's sort of a fading back but it's
early I'm often here to one branch at a
time so that can be a clue and if you
snip that branch off and you peel away
the bark in the upper right corner you
can see some Browns streaking in the
canyon it just subtle I found it to be
quite subtle but that is diagnostic for
verticillium the brown streaking in the
cambium not much you can do there's
really no spray for verticillium it's a
sirloin pathogen it's difficult to
manage a couple of things you'd want to
do you can remove the affected parts and
hope that you know that contains it I've
found that basically you start just
removing the plant on the installment
plant plan or your take off one branch
and next year take off another branch
alright next year take off another
branch certainly if that tree dies you
would not want to plant resistant
species back into that site because it's
sort of more in persistence so you
wouldn't want to put another mate though
like you wouldn't want to replace the
Japanese maple that died of verticillium
with another maple you might want to put
there you know there are a lot of plants
that are resistant to verticillium so
you would want to use those rather than
susceptible diseases
susceptible species okay well that is
the quick overview of some of the most
common diseases that we see in central
new york and happy disease hunting this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu